64 da ist das schild da ist das stimmt
so und wir gehen immer hier
so zeigt wie die rückennummer ende wie
gesagt ende ist die taste drücken muss
keiner haben sie das so gemacht haben
und ziehen wir unser schild hier an
soz s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge wanted mit dabei ist
wieder der marius und wir gehen direkt
auf den server drauf dabei also
interesse die beinahe pgh der connection
era das nicht schlimm das reißt und
wieso hab ich ein ice der 60 fest läuft
ist es echt seltsam dieser komische
benutzer sound ist wieder da allerdings
noch ein eis dann wisst ihr was ich
jetzt machen wir machen jetzt erstmal
ein neues schwert das hab ich vom im
internet ihr abgeschaut
gleichzeitig muss man das rezept wenn
man das hier haben hiermit biblio kraft
so reisten damals zack zack zack zack
man kann damit schwer machen wo ist das
wo ist dieses blöde schwer 30 hier so
frost world 10 militär match damit macht
schon mal drei mehr als die erschwerten
oder ja böse und hier ist es läuft auf
jeden fall muss erst mal irgendwas
benötige ich bin auch gott hat noch kein
einziges mal gestorben machen auch
erstmal eine spitzhacke weil wir jetzt
noch kurz runter gehen werden und farmen
werden und zwar werde ich mir dieser
folge einen schild machen
ich habe mich in dem letztlich von die
atlantic kraft das sind die
amerikanischen youtube für die dieses
motto pack hier überhaupt es gebaut
wurde habe ich gesehen dass man sich
schilder machen kann
dort soll die tour läuft
und ja da nimmst du ein bisschen reisen
suchen und wenn doch mal gucken dass wir
hier ein paar mittags bangen so zu sagen
ob sie auf reisen geht weiter dieses
dran ist mit doppel weh so nervig dass
ich ein bisschen brutal das schon
komisch wenn man halt nie mit auf den
weg ich bin der ich war ja aber es ist
geil alles zu tun hätten und es ist und
das ist ja noch gar nicht mal noch gar
nicht mal das ende der veranstaltung es
gibt hier also dieses später zehn medi
damage und es gibt leute es gibt einfach
schwerte die am 40
der mensch in diesem spiel ja das ist
aber auch die stärksten nicht gebannt
wurden
das was über 45 jahren gewandt weil es
dann wirst du okay ist oder weil
stammkeeper egal jetzt auch schnell alt
küpers sogar one hit krass alter nice
yahoo läuft bei der sg würde schon sagen
also läuft bei der sks muss noch kurz
ein bisschen reisen suchen wo ich finde
zwar keins alter mache com
okay sagt svs ewig für monster in der
höhe nicht richtig ausgeleuchtet
ja so marius huber alter scheiße ich
hätte vielleicht nicht so nah ans mikro
genua ist die reisen jetzt sehr dankbar
das hat er glaube ich weiter zu hören
was passiert eigentlich wenn ein krieg
papier in der nähe von eisen explodiert
wird es abgebaut
das ist weg
schlecht ja ich habe auch schon zehn
level also mann max nicht so gut wenn
das werk ist ja das war super alter ich
wohl hätte die teile teilweise ich mit
diesem geld wird das übel gala ich freue
mich richtig auf die pvp phase habe ich
bock drauf ich schon kurz mal wie viele
brauchen für dieses schild hier ist
keiner da so hier unten allen sieben
eisen brauchen wir
man kann der mich hier das habe ich auch
in diesem ding gesehen wäre mein ende
drückt das durch das keinen fall den
anderen leuten im projekt verraten
das ist echt gut also in der
wüstenregion nur der wüsten liga west
beste wüstenregion ja genau beschreibt
aber jetzt mal hashtag wüstenregion
instrumentaler gemacht schon am zeigt er
uns sofort bis jetzt habe ich bei mir
nur von hacks gesehen grüßen dich aber
ich habe alle mal hashtag wüstenregion
rein und da macht jetzt ein bisschen
teambuilding so welches ende drücke da
seht ihr es hier kann ich das schild
entpacken und da noch schmuck ringen
flog sogar handschuhe kann man diese
krise
und ja wir haben jetzt sechs eisenerz
und noch ein eisen waren im inventar das
heißt um genug für so ein schild und ich
glaube diese schilder sind ziemlich
brutal was was von schutz herangeht
oder um es altes eisen hier ist eisen
nicht zu knapp alter ego
ja ja nein altenarbeit folge der körper
ist direkt in mir explodiert und es hat
vier herzen schaden gemacht nur leider
ist auch nicht egal ich bin ich schon
ganz gut geklappt jetzt müsse sie wird
den weg herausfinden
also wenn du selber hast dann
dort alles wenn du warst ja irgendwas
halt irgendwas was man bekomme ich nicht
jetzt eure seite welcher drüben
altenheim
ich hasse das ich verkaufe ich immer
diesen höhen es ist eben das gleiche
habe das gleich mit aber ich witze
machen selbst einer kurzen kette leute
sehen uns wieder wenn ich aus dem wieder
rausgekommen bin nämlich 20 die 20
minuten
ich hab's gefunden
geräusche ja und wir sind hier wieder in
der in building in unserem
provisorischen in unsere unterkunft so
alt ist einfach 64 eisen drin miese
zeiten da ist das schild da ist das
steht so und wir gerne hier sozusagen
wir drückt nochmal ende wie gesagt ende
ist die taste drücken muss keine ahnung
sieht das so gemacht haben und ziehen
wir unser schild hier an
yeah an den rüstungs punkten hat sich
nichts verändert aber ich glaube das ist
richtig gut hier punkte so defensive nie
wenn ihr wisst ihr könnt ja mal in die
kommentare schreiben
falls ihren plan habt wie viel das so
macht sie zu kaufen tomaten
kommentar schreibt und keinen plan hat
heute werden auch 7 30 roby falter
werden hier so hart gefahren nicht laut
bafa wird auf 730 gold ich hoffe es geht
für ihn klar wenn ich mich dabei bediene
vba gibt es dann die piste war aber viel
von ihr und ja wir müssen uns auf jeden
fall auch mahlweizen farben machen
ich glaub ich geh jetzt mal ein paar
mehr durchgespielt habt das braucht
nämlich dringend bisschen weizen märzen
weil ich habe herausgefunden man kann
richtig geil richtig geile nahrung aus
weizen machen und zwar wenn man neun
wenn man neun weizen so in form einer
truhe anordnet also wie man so eine
truhe macht oder vorne dann kriegt man
einen donut raus madonna und der donut
der ist echt geil der regeneriert
nämlich einfach acht hunger punkte
selbst gesehen wir wollen hinten die
scheiß creeper alter ist noch aber gibt
mittel gegen die france
ja ja der hat auch strahlt auf die
shirts gedruckt
bei mir in wien ich weiß nicht warum die
session rettet er die drops endlich
keine angst mehr haben müssen vor diesen
fächern euro das war nicht so schlau
vertriebsdirektor gegangen ich hab
nichts gemacht
hey vielleicht ach scheiße dicker weißer
baumwolle herbekommt ich muss dringend
ein bett bauen
ja natürlich aber hast die chance
gesehen
ich nehme ich auch nicht ich hab nur in
der folge von wer ihm gesehen dass sie
direkt am anfang so hier schafe gefunden
hat ja du könntest wenn du ganz viele
spinnen kids könntest du über die
kräften ja ja ja laut werden ja aber das
ist extrem aufwendig ja gut man braucht
acht werden ja das ist nicht wenig die
sind so viele mops ein bisschen mock
waren all diese kleinen mops können es
schon mal fast nichts mehr anhaben das
ist schon geil
ok aber in engem 1
rund 20 creeper alter die ist einfach
nicht weniger das nicht cool
malta ist mir zu riskant
jetzt wird langsam so berichten die
erfahrung mit und die coins da kann
immer tolle sache machen ach ja übrigens
ich sammle auch direkt mal den kaktus 1
ich habe nämlich noch was erfahren leute
es gibt so viele geile waffen hier im
spiel
es gibt eine eine krabbeln kann ohne
dass eine kanone die man aus krabben
clown macht und die macht im 20 range
image und mit verschieden
deswegen braucht es hier ab
vielleicht suchen wir die krabbel ist
vielleicht noch zu stark vom 1 das weiß
ich suri meinte seien erfolge dass die
haben 160 leben und die wohn hinten wenn
man keine risse hat
das ist alles was wir nicht so gut aber
hier gibt soviel kaktus in der wüste
alter wie als wissen dinge müssen nicht
alle die krabben machen du musst du
nicht bauen das ist ein portabler waffe
die bauteile also so fest zu erteilen
nee das ist ein portabler waffe aber
dass noch keiner da kannst du überall
hin mitnehmen
im pvp die ok jetzt genug davon
teilweise sind die halt echt schnell
down okay aber wir haben auch eine
tomate die kann man auch essen
vielleicht machen wir auch den ersten
dungeon was meinst du ja könnte man
machen gewesen ist auch wie viele ende
mai kommt rand kommt ran kommt alle ran
ich kenne diese schilder brings hat echt
ne da dieses schild ist es was mir so
viel leben wird also so viel
verteidigung 24 leben direkt die s ich
habe mich mal veri um gibt mir diesen
turm zombie der lotter freisfeld
indikators wright und macht so viel
kaputt ist nicht alles vorüber jetzt
muss vielleicht auch ein bisschen
regenerieren
größte probleme mit diesem mit den
captains ist dass man das ihr einheit
einem look back geben und dass man auf
doppelte sprinten muss das heißt man
kann nicht einfach weiteren sondern muss
erst wieder ansetzen und deshalb ist
optimal oder die flächen vielleicht käme
auch einfach ein bisschen aufpassen
damit auch nicht unendlich leben gut ist
auch aufgefallen sie meine erste folge
gehabt dass ich einfach volle oft
abgespart bin obwohl es gar nicht so
mega knapp war
aber jetzt für alle die gleich
verstanden haben man man da muss einfach
die folge die aufnahme beenden wenn man
stirbt deswegen machten sich halt schon
wirklich sorgen
und ja
über reagiert vielleicht auch weil das
leben mein alter ich hab schon zehn
pferden kein ding für mich zum eine
nacht durchgefahren hab jetzt schon mal
zehn fäden zusammen
ach da drüben sind wie ok magazin wird
allerdings vergessen 848 für ein bett
also vertreiben
glaube ich zumindest als ich wusste
vorher ehrlich gesagt auch nicht dass
man sich hier wolle aus verden machen
kann das rechtlich auch nicht so logisch
teilweise habe ich noch solche zusammen
bildungsmittel das habe ich dann bei mir
ging's bei wer ihm gesehen
danke an dich wenn du hast schon mal
direkt gegnerischen region geholfen
filmstoff de france hatte ja wir sollten
uns auf jeden fall mal ein weizenfeld
anlegen
wer hat das gemacht
ja klar ich hab das alles von ihm
gesehen
also wie gesagt was weizen kann man das
machen und donation wirklich okay 88
ernährungs punkte
800 punkte das schon krass oder ja und
wie gesagt man kann sich ich hab ich
hatte was gesagt zur großen schwarzen
also ich sag nur so viel aus diesen
kursen charts die diese frost
zielgruppen kann man sich eine richtig
üble rüstung machen und zwar eine
richtig üble ist ja eine rüstung mit der
man tolle sachen machen kann nicht
fliegen was habe ich fliege seit kurzem
einem video zeigen oder
aber solche der soll es ihr gut machen
wir machen sieg und machen ein geheimnis
draus es geht aber eine richtig geile
rüstung und für die pharmig jetzt und
dann holen wir doch erst mal packen
immer den kaktus rein so rotten flesh
masse whatever strings machen uns jetzt
mal hier schön wohl sagt zack zack da
machen uns immer ein lied einfach mein
bett der bild gesagt vermisse ein
crafting table oder er muss euch nicht
nur helfer braucht man drei volle film
betty anne über 230 braucht drei wolle
also ein denkfehler wieder drei wolle
motto frag ja okay wir holen das
wahrscheinlich nochmal nach unten und
dann greifen wir 2 3 mio weil er das
geld spenden
ich kenne ich auch meinen schmerz kein
ding hat die engen gedrückt so mäßig
vielleicht gemacht da jemals und gang
rein also darum wisst ihr wie ich meine
nicht wieder mainz war das nicht sie ist
ja so ich würde schon gerne mit auch nie
arbeitet dann einfach zuviel frau
produziert und ich bin nicht so der
freund von so viel produzieren nicht
voll geil ich möchte möglichst nah an
den aufnahmen thema dran sein ich weiß
nicht ja ja okay gut ja das verstehe ich
auch das ist eine persönliche macke
dänemark ist es nichts versteht ihr
steak ja schon an vw
bester mann und wir haben jetzt wir
brauchen noch zwei streams ja okay die
spinnen gibt es auch tagsüber hier das
ja auch kein schritt gehen wir mal
darüber
oder vielleicht mache jetzt einfach den
dungeon und manchen guck mal hier schau
mal wie lange schon aufnehmen alter
schon wieder 18 minuten nach 1
das geht so schnell altern ein
schauen wir kurz bitte auf die urne
also so zeitmäßig zwei minuten wartet da
drinnen sport sponsor spinnen oder ihr
müsst eigentlich bin ja so ist der dispo
auf tagsüber in den dungeons oder ja
komm schon spinne sportpolitischen aus
konnte dann habe ich einfach mal oben
eine spinne gerade mal den skeleton
sport überhaupt bogen und ich habe acht
werden sehr geil
denn das ist doch mal
übrigens alle zusammen wie man am besten
am effektivsten
in den nächsten folgen bei einem opfer
also es wird ja vielleicht hatte ich
vielleicht habt ihr auch schon
irgendwelche videos gesehen immer so
einfach abfallen baut also ich weiß vom
prinzip her so man lässt sich immer
irgendwie 20 blöcke tief fallen also vom
wasser irgendwohin 23 blöcke tief fallen
und mussten
wie willst du das bonner dahin gekommen
ach ja dafür muss man dafür muss man das
mid caps ihr glaube ich verzaubern das
habe ich in einem video von riemer
gesehen der wollte das match abbauen
aber es geht nur mit caps so oder so auf
jeden fall
ich habe auch noch keinen plan wie
verzauberungen funktionieren bei diesem
motto also auf jeden fall es bleibt
spannend
ich mache jetzt noch schnell dass man
weg hier fertig so 123 ja und
wunderschön und ihr könnt auch mal in
die kommentare schreiben ob ihr hier
treffen wir sind zombie unsere bude
locker kontern herr k
ihr könnt man die kommentare schreiben
ob ihr hatte ich mache ich noch die
politik könnten die kommentare schreiben
ob ihr bock habt dass ich mir zwecks
reinmache hier weil momentan ist noch
auf die vor ort keine ahnung vielleicht
habt ihr mehr lust drauf aber ich könnte
mir glaube ich auf sechs reinmachen so
wird mir sowas geschickt ständig sowie
das unser bett und wir können jetzt noch
nicht schaffen egal also sport noch
nicht gesetzt egal leute dann sind ja
wir sind gut in der zeit und da würde
ich sagen
haut rein es geht auch für verspannt
weiter hier mit mops bonnern vielleicht
mit mob fallen mitteilerin waffen auf
jeden fall und vielleicht mit der einen
anderen special rüstung sind würde ich
sagen haut rein macht's gut und